i've
never read berserk i don't know anything
about the story other than that there's
a big boy that swings a big sword and
today i'll be reviewing the first arc of
berserk
completely blind for those of you that
are new over the last year i've
completed blind read-through review
series on hunter hunter
jojo's bizarre adventure and of course
the now over 1 000 chapters long
one piece from the beginning berserk was
a story i knew had its fans but
due to the absence of a companion anime
to make these videos with
i decided pretty early on that while i'm
sure berserk is an amazing story
it wasn't a story i could review without
changing my entire format
and so i put it to the side that is
until i opened twitter one day and
saw this now naturally i don't like to
dwell on very serious subject matter all
too often but
the outpouring of passion for this man's
work in response to his tragic passing
not only captured my attention but
really put into perspective
what this series must have meant to so
many people across the world
i think we all have a story like that
that's touched our hearts in one way or
another and
it made me wonder that despite the
difficult production these berserk
reviews might demand
maybe there's a way
[Music]
all right so let's get one thing
straight first this
isn't going to be one of my typical
review series berserk is so long and so
manga focused that the best i can do
is one review a month that means one out
of every four of my videos will be a
berserk review until such time i finish
and what is not ideal for some of you i
assume it gives me time to digest the
content and above all
else will give my editor the time to
create these videos with all the manga
panels you love
so with that said it's time for me to
dive into the first page of berserk
okay in storytelling i find few aspects
to be more irritating or offensive
than when a story is boring
but let me tell you berserk is not
boring and while i've never been an
individual to be won over by big man
swings big sword good
gods to be swinging that sword pretty
good like i said in the beginning i had
literally zero expectations going into
this but damn
this story from the opening pages right
all the way through is
balls to the wall gore violence and
tragedy
now it's clear that this arc is an
establishing one in many respects
it flashes from setting to setting
encounter to encounter until it doesn't
but that's okay because this arc's main
objective
is to teach us about one character above
all others
guts but that's not to say that this arc
doesn't have some stunning visuals
brilliant narrative choices and some of
the best paneling i've seen from a
series in
years but be warned it gets pretty
intense from here on in
i mean the opening pages alone are crazy
so
like i'm sitting there holding this
leather-bound behemoth of a volume with
two hands by the way because it's a
thick and heavy
boy i opened the first page and bam this
is what i see
now i know we're taught in english class
to grab our reader's attention in the
opening paragraph or as soon as we can
but
geez i don't think that this is what mr
troy was talking about when he said that
and it's not at all how i thought i'd be
spending my saturday but
the opening chapters primarily concern
themselves with establishing the world
the main character's guts and a smaller
supporting character called puck who
will no doubt play a massive role in the
dynamic moving forward
which i am very grateful for seeing as
the closest thing guts could muster to
light-hearted banter
would be him clutching someone's light
heart in his fist
now full disclosure that actually hasn't
happened yet in my read
through but i would be surprised if it
doesn't ever happen given what this
introductory portion has shown me thus
far
in saying that the first few chapters
did a fantastic job in sucking me into
the story
which given that this material was
written in the 80s gave me tremendous
hope for the future of this series
normally with more middle-of-the-road
serializations from this era
the age of the product is felt however a
number of properties managed to achieve
that
timeless feel with their focus and
dedication to character
and world building thankfully berserk
does just that
berserk feels like it could have been
written this year in many ways
helped in part by its dedication to the
medieval dark fantasy aesthetic
colouring the encounters and choices
made by characters from the weaponry the
armor or
even the transportation used need to get
to the next town faster well you gotta
hit your ride with some randomer on the
back of a horse and cart all hateful
eight style but
the crowning jewel of the story for me
has to be how it imbues different
individuals with their respective
characteristics
in other words i love this story's
characterization
guts is a character that from the moment
i saw him filled me with dread i had the
worst feeling in the back of my mind
that he would just be another mindless
personality-less muscle-bound meathead
for us the audience to self-insert into
but he's not in fact i thought the
anglo-mura approached the character with
felt both appropriate for the time
and retroactively worked for my
sensibilities today he very much feels
like the stoic action hero appropriate
for the time period but
there's a little more under the surface
to keep me interested a tragic backstory
were drip fed over the course of the
narrative that
i'm sure we'll see more of as time
passes by but what helped me
latch onto him the most was how his
actions do not match
what he says just listening to him you'd
swear he's the most heartless man alive
but
in reality he's probably harvested more
hearts from the corpse of his victims
okay i'm kidding jokes aside what he
says versus how he acts colored my
impression of him early which
i think is great from the moment we meet
him as he wanders into a seemingly
random town
to the hostility he's met with and
ultimately the violence he strikes down
unto them
it's almost like he's trying to convince
himself that he is a
certain way focused on his mission to
achieve his goal which
we still don't know yet at this point at
numerous times in this story early on he
vocally disparages and denigrates those
in society that are weak
as both pathetic and not worth life let
alone his consideration
like puck an elf type creature he
stumbles across by chance and because of
who he is
god shows no sympathy or care despite
his circumstances and yet
whenever he seems to encounter someone
in need including poc he gets involved
more often than he would let you think
and if that were it i
wouldn't have thought to address it
there are lots of characters like that
in anime vegeta very much
is that character right now in dragon
ball super to a much more
light-hearted degree might i add someone
that doesn't want to show how much he
cares and hides it behind a thin facade
but ultimately when the chips are down
he does help every time
but that's not who gutz is every time
guts might do something accidentally or
overtly righteous
he shows visible frustration with
himself as if he's scolding or trying to
suppress who he truly is
instead of accepting it and at this
point we're not really sure why he does
this
this makes him not only an interesting
anti-hero of sorts but also a character
that is defined by his actions
and by what he says with each means of
exposition showing and telling
working in opposition to one another
forming a narrative puzzle of sorts that
pulls double duty
creating a sense of depth and conflict
within the character naturally while
also hinting towards a scarring history
or backstory for guts as the protagonist
leaving us as an audience wonder why the
charade
why the conflict of action and mindset
and for us to ask that sort of question
this early on to achieve that level of
character in the first few chapters
it's nothing short of remarkable and
that's not even to make mention of these
strange existential orwellian dreams
he's haunted by hinting perhaps out of
fear he has of what tasks lay before him
on his journey
only time will tell i guess oh also this
brand or scar on his neck summons evil
spirits so
not ideal could it be connected to the
nightmares well
i mean i've read all of the arcs so yeah
it sure seems to be the case and either
way
it makes for some really cool looking
imagery and while i'm on the topic of
imagery
man this manga looks good like
that says i say made the ball
i'm very impressed not just with the
anatomy layouts or use of shadows but
the restraint he employs to draw
attention to certain aspects and to not
clutter his pages also
for instance right after pucks will they
won't they budding bromance with gut
starts the two of them hit a ride
through the dark monster-ridden force
with an
old man and a young girl this for me was
where the manga
really caught my attention in the best
of ways it's important in this moment
for us to see
the dead rising from the depths of the
forest as if spewing out from the fog
and miura's use of white space helps to
achieve that nicely
also i'm a big fan of spooky scary
skeletons
so extra points for that and once again
he do be swinging that big sword pretty
big
clearly this was drawn by a mangaka that
loved what he was doing the attention to
detail the generous page space dedicated
to the initial strike
with ample time given to the follow
through on the following pages
every single time he swings this fridge
door at someone it's given special
treatment
as it should it's an awesome shot it
looks so good in fact i didn't even
really mind the fact that the only
reason they came into conflict with the
skeletons in the first place came down
to the idiotic choice of a little girl
oh she's a demon and she trapped them on
purpose
hey that's pretty good i'm not even
remotely kidding when i say that around
every corner something happens that
quickly grabs your attention in this
manga and it never lingers long enough
either to
get boring or overstay its welcome in
fact it felt like miura was trying his
best to express what these scenes needed
in as efficient a way as possible
take for example this scene with the
little girl first we see that guts is
busy with the spooky
second we see puck notice something in
the carriage third we see the
disembodied head of the driver
fourth we see guts and puck react with
gutz's reaction reinforcing his good
tough guy persona
hesitating not wanting to hurt the
little girl and in the process
gets stabbed this is all slowly but
effectively building tension to the
final shot
where he swings his big sword yet again
only this time
unlike all of the other instances that
preceded this big swing
there's no focus on the gore of the
situation there's no focus on how badass
the moment might be
it's looked on from afar as the dramatic
and tragic
unfortunate death that it is one that
befell a young
innocent girl this this is the
difference between a mangaka that just
wants to draw cool stuff and a manga
card that wants to draw a great
manga that he believes in furthermore
kintara miura
really leans into the anguish
frustration and hurt in both guts and
puck
during the aftermath as they have to
contend with this growing swarm of the
undead and again the focus isn't on the
awesome visuals that do
eventually come but instead it's
focusing on the struggle and mental
state of guts as he coughs up blood
and staggers to his feet before he
eventually psychs himself
up pushes his humanity to the side and
bodies the seemingly bottomless swarm of
the undead
in what i can only describe as an
impossibly exhausting effort with it
being once again
presented expertly in this impressive
two-page spread
and i say impressive for a specific
reason
what's interesting about this shot to me
at least is how miura decided to present
the character of guts
ask any artist where expression comes
from and nine times out of ten they will
often say either the eyes the mouth or
some place on the face itself
most action shots in manga place heavy
emphasis on this for that reason
but as you can see miura drew him
without a face
in this shot instead opting to shroud it
in shadow
now on top of it looking cool it plays a
further role in visually communicating
his characterization
made all the more effective when you
realize that the previous massive swings
of a sword that we've seen
came with this shadow effect over his
face also reinforcing the notion that
wild guts can bring himself to perform
these grotesque acts and ignore the
consequences of the life he leads for
him to actually live
with it he has to push a significant
part of himself away
removing his humanity both figuratively
through what he says
and demonstrated visually through the
shadow over his face
in these illustrations in other words
he's forcing himself to become
a monster to defeat these monsters a
perfect marriage of the visual
and narrative utility and as dawn breaks
through the darkness of the night
bringing an end to the battle an
ethereal otherworldly voice
bellows from deep in the woods citing
and i quote
we are always watching and you belong to
me
we want your heart in the past gus has
criticized the weak time and again
because
he believes that the weak can't be free
and now
having heard this voice i'm starting to
see why guts
places so much emphasis on freedom now
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
jokes aside everyone g field is being
the best sponsor i've worked with in my
career in all honesty the people are
amazing and there's virtually no filter
or script for me to read off of
as made evident by this commercial they
allowed me to make i've tried the
product and i sincerely think it's
delicious so if you'd like to try it for
yourself or want to help out the channel
click the link in the description
below thank you everyone
what am i doing here
what are any of us doing here my god
wow that really hurts anyway where was i
oh yeah the meaning of life by guts
the next section is by far and away the
most substantial story sequence we've
received thus far and
i think if you were to ask anyone who's
read this material what the best part of
the arc was
it'd be this mini arc concerning guts's
dance with the evil count of this poor
misfortunate village
it's got all the normal bells and
whistles i've come to expect from this
story thus far
only everything is turned up to 11 with
more gore than i've seen in the manga
with a touch of body horror
and by a touch of body horror i mean
holy hell what the hell is that thing
kill it with fire
up until now the story rightfully has
focused on characterizing guts and puck
as well as fleshing out the wider world
and its mechanics for us as an audience
now that those introductions are done
it's time to settle into the first
substantial miniak of the story one that
i noticed may have heavily influenced an
anime i saw a few years ago
so obviously in fact that i'd find it
hard to believe that they aren't at the
very least
influenced either by each other or by
the same source
it can't be a coincidence but yeah i'll
make sure to mention that when i get
there
but for now this story kicks off in a
very western fashion
as our lone ranger guts encounters a
tyrannical vindictive and seemingly
careless count
after he enters his town um
yeah this count isn't a great leader
after having finished this arc looking
back i think it's interesting to see how
many parallels were being set up right
from the get-go between the count and
guts respectively
subtle as they are i think it helped to
build up what eventually became a
similarity between
them as well as a powerful theme in this
story
exploring what lengths people will go to
in order to deal
with pain loss and suffering on a plot
front there's some interesting set
pieces that really made this field
distinct to a lot
of the other scenarios we've encountered
leading up everything else before now
i realize was just training wheels and i
say this because once we learned the
count's true intentions and physical
makeup i was greeted by imagery that
actually made me wince with how
disgusting
and horrific everything looked primarily
once the cow starts possessing people
and
growing his slug-like slimy body inside
them like some sort of weird
parasite what so okay remember what i
spoke about this arc clearly being
inspired or maybe
inspiring a specific anime i watched
well it all came to my attention in the
third chapter of the guardian of desire
within which there's an image that looks
very reminiscent of numerous shots from
the parasite the maxim franchises
monster
so close in fact that i'm convinced this
is where parasite guy got his idea from
but i'm not certain that's the case both
this manga
and parasite came out at roughly the
same time and given that both share
such similar imagery with this concept
one is either emulating the other or
they both saw the same inspiration from
a third party elsewhere
either way it's a cool as hell shot and
one that's remained in my memory
since long after from a choreography
standpoint the fight scenes in this arc
just get better and better by building
on the prior material in the story
throughout this story we've been
introduced to the series of different
weapons in guts's arsenal like the giant
fridge to i
mean big sword uh his concealed crossbow
and to my surprise
this massive explosive flamethrower on
his wrist
and yes it's as awesome as it sounds and
through two primary plot threads in this
arc
we're shown the depths of what godz is
capable of and what makes the count tick
is he 100 evil
or is there something or someone that he
cares about
from a narrative standpoint i like how
they handle the nuance of the count's
dwindling humanity
naturally he's a despicable monster that
locks his own child away from the world
but he's still a father that while
making horrific decisions here and there
and everywhere
also more or less is coming from a place
of love
and fear of losing that love and while
it doesn't justify it it at least
humanizes him somewhat and as he
possesses
his subordinates and fights with guts in
gripping confrontations like small close
quarter exchanges and sellers or
up staircases he becomes more and more
of a monster both figuratively and
physically with his very design
reflecting that simultaneously thanks to
puck that horror is balanced through
light-hearted carefully exposed insight
into the daughter's life or lack thereof
but
before we proceed there's still one more
character i
haven't mentioned and his name is vargas
effectively he serves the narrative
purpose of highlighting the counts
cruelty
and guts's increasing ambivalence
towards justice
vargas is introduced to the story early
on after guts runs into trouble in the
town by bailing him out of a dicey
situation he's disfigured poor and like
many others had
tragedy befall him and his family by way
of the cow's cruelty
and he also has this weird egg face
thing that guts
has a lot of interest in more on that in
just a second
though at every turn guts refuses to
avenge his family and to take down the
count
even after vargas's execution which
offered up some brilliantly effective
moments to demonstrate gutz's mindset
versus how he's trying to feel it's an
aspect of this arc i
thoroughly enjoyed watching how he keeps
trying to be something he's not
he tries to be detached cold and
dispassionate he tries to tell himself
this
lies so often that it directly results
in the execution of vargas
the man that reached out to him when he
needed help
despite trying to distance himself from
his own humanity guts's disappointment
and frustration
rises he cares but doesn't want to
he doesn't want to hurt more than he
already does so he tells himself this
useful fiction that strength is the only
thing that matters and that the weak
mean nothing in order to continue living
in relative peace of mind
and as the circumstances worsen
eventually he finds a way of tackling
the issue he vows to kill the count
again
lying to himself that it's for no other
apparent reason than that he wants to or
perhaps
needs to be a certain way to think that
had he managed to reconcile the sight of
himself earlier vargas could have been
saved it's the first in what i bet will
become a long list of consequences for
guts to live with the eventual fight
however that takes place
is brilliant in its own right taking
elements we've learned about guts and
placing him in a situation where his
back is very literally and figuratively
up against a wall under pressure is
where we learn what characters are
capable of and
interestingly gut shows how perceptive
he is by taking the counts one weakness
his daughter theresa hostage in the heat
of battling there's some terrific
imagery that superbly communicates how
bloodthirsty he can bring himself to be
but i think this mode of action works
for guts because
he recognizes what it is about the count
that he feels he understands he believes
the count won't attack his daughter
and finally speaking more broadly i just
love how
weird this story gets just when i
thought that gods had defeated the count
there and then
they all go to another dimension thanks
to that weird egg thing
i mean we've gone i would argue on a
steady progression from what appeared to
be an angry man with a big sword in a
medieval setting
to a full-on dark fantasy epic complete
with dimensional demons
and an angry man with a big sword that
also has a troubled backstory
this mini arc within the greater black
swordsman arc is hugely entertaining it
provides a culmination of what little
exposition we've been given about the
character of guts up until this point
and the antagonist he's facing in the
count
highlights a similarity between the two
of them but in doing so
brings to the forefront the greatest
difference they share while each of
their respective outlooks and decisions
are made out of fear doubt and a host of
negative issues
in the face of overwhelming sadness as
well as emotional and physical torment
the count in the past chose the easy
option to remove his humanity
to numb the pain and loss of his wife
whereas guts
chose to live with it and uses it as
fuel to drive him on to do the
great things that we've seen him
demonstrate with him throughout this arc
having many ups and downs
successes and shortcomings ultimately
resulting in his defeated
limp body resting on the floor yet even
in the face of what must be
overwhelming pain depicted through his
broken fingers and dangling limbs
he's still as tenacious as ever
gets up ever struggling ever pushing
towards
freedom freedom from his circumstances
and freedom i'd wager at this point
from whatever is haunting him in his
past if that isn't inspirational
i don't know what is okay so now that
we're in this weird
demon dimension we're greeted by the
council of evil looking characters with
the preceding scenes serving to
emphasize for us the slippery slope such
thinking like the count has implemented
brings him having already done the
unthinkable to his wife before
he is now destined for hell he's owned
by the demons making it even easier to
commit the same heinous acts
again to his daughter however this is
emphasized instead to amplify our
appreciation for the count's
ultimate sacrifice he loved his daughter
too much to give her up for his own sake
the little humanity that remained was
enough to make
the right decision it should go without
saying also that the visuals during this
section are spectacular with the
highlight being
the wide shot of the dimension and the
souls reaching out of hell
and grabbing a hold of the count himself
vargas and all
however in what i anticipate will become
typical berserk fashion
the count story ends by reaching out one
last time
for his daughter's hand a request denied
specifically and drawn attention to
before in the story
and throughout their relationship always
denied before
this time however shocked by the
situation and what's come to light
she for the first time reaches back but
it's too late
his time is up poetic and beautifully
tragic
after that we get a terrific glimpse at
what i assume will be the big bad for
the foreseeable future
someone that to guts seems to be a
familiar face
confirmed through flashbacks to their
time spent to soldiers
what i love about that inclusion to the
story is what it offered by way
of once again visual direction and
exposition instead of telling us how
they feel about each other we're
shown taking all of this demonic glitz
and glamour out of the equation and we
have a story concerning the relationship
between
two men one where once upon a time he
tried to help guts up to his feet after
battle
but now he quite literally is beating
him to the ground
insisting he stay there we don't get
much from this exchange and in reality i
don't know much about this dynamic yet
but if guts's relentless grit and
determination carries him to his feet
when he has nothing left at all
in a last-ditch effort to get a clean
shot on this guy
it made me more than a little interested
in how the relationship has spawned
this reaction between them interestingly
in the same way many games begin
by showing you how weak you are
berserk's introductory arc
reminds guts how weak he is and by
extension how trapped
he really is haunted by his branded
reminder
and if it ended there i'd have been
happy if it ended there it would have
been a fitting conclusion to what the
story had been trying to achieve
but that wasn't enough for berserk
after this scene it decided to drop one
more a scene that i think
provided the most powerful note in all
of the arc
throughout this review you might have
noticed that i've at
every opportunity praised what i believe
to be berserk
and quintaro miora's greatest attributes
their dedication to consistent character
writing and devotion
to visual storytelling and in this final
scene
we get both of those in spades
after narrowly escaping this strange
demonic dimension and having witnessed
the death of the count
just three individuals remain in a room
together
the devastated theresa a confused puck
and guts just about managing a hobble
aided by his sword acting as a crutch an
apt to use for the instrument we have
learned
alleviated his suffering before through
action and while
our eyes are initially drawn to guts and
his wounds
the grief of theresa quickly takes hold
having witnessed the horrific scenes
mere moments ago
tragically she feels no other way to
deal with these feelings contemplating
taking her own life puck ever the
compassionate voice
tries to comfort her but nothing seems
to work she's heard and seen
too much horror to ever be the same
again and
that's when we get guts chiming in
offering her a dagger she's now
inches from doing so before the ground
gives way beneath her clutching for life
she grasps at gutz's sword
bleeding from her fingers she climbs
back up now ironed with renewed fire in
her heart
a hatred for guts claiming that this was
all his fault and that she will
one day kill him guts staggers off
laughing with a cocky demeanor until
she's out of sight
soon after his face crumbles to end the
chapter
and the arc having granted theresa the
means with which to liberate herself
from her one time prison what a
stupendously
orchestrated scene climaxing with a
telling revelation not only informing us
of how compassionate guts truly
is but also further pointing us towards
the reality that gut shares
more in common with this young girl than
she even thinks
taking themes from this arc and
concentrating them into one magnificent
gut punch
that honestly left me teary-eyed and
excited for more
before starting this review i knew
virtually nothing about berserk as a
story in my head i worried it would be
an action-heavy narrative light affair
indulging its readers on a very
rudimentary and shallow level with
little at all to say
i was wrong what i discovered was a
lovingly composed
tortured introduction to a fascinating
story detailing themes of hope
fear and tragedy penned by one of the
most impressive manga artists
i've read the work of thank you all for
recommending me this story
rest in peace kentaro meora i can't wait
to sink my teeth
into more of your material thanks for
watching
[Music]
foreign
you